comes up with it puts the speed on and
then pulls up
play by forms galanari for three
yes straight away three
for danilo dominar well it's been bobby
portis off the bench
for milwaukee and danilo golonari off
the bench here
for nate mcmillan and atlanta 16 points
now for gallinari
forbes intended pass hiatus
is last touched by the fox great defense
staying in front of
andre tacumbo and right now he's in a
trail position
walked into a three right there
hawks fight three final minute
third quarter bad pass here come the box
forbes wide open for three
[Applause]
and a foul giannis ended up with the
ball and he ends up being
trey young is down here you're wondering
if he's tired or did
something happen on that last play
apparently he slipped
taught it right here
yeah oh it looks like you may have
stepped on the official
the official's foot yeah right there a
little tweak right there
little tweak of the ankle on the
official sean wright's
right foot
[Music]
something to watch going forward now he
i'm looking at his ankles
he does wear those ankle pads on both
ankles so hopefully that gave him a
little bit more support
[Applause]
and here's another look at at that play
right
yep right there it's a little bit of a
tweak
timeout taken hawks by three
the eastern conference finals on tnt is
presented by
a tnt so another concern for head coach
mate mcdonald you see trae young headed
back
to the hawks locker room
after he took that spill
hawks by three with 29 seconds
remaining in the third as the yadas
will shoot a couple no back in the
locker room and no john collins
on the bench with those four fouls and
now the crowd
serenading giannis at the free-throw
line he's
four of nine thus far
and he draws the foul oh he's tied up
he's tied up
how big has ocon move in
for nate mcmillan then playing spot
minutes throughout
these playoffs and in this series and
you hear the crowd now
the roar trey young back on the floor
here
for the hops this after the sprained
right ankle
went to the locker room in the final
moments of the third quarter and he's
right back let's see how he's able to
react
nice and tinnitus broken up got an arm
able to take it away who broke it up oh
congruent
the length quick leaping ability
here's lou williams out to young
golem not a foul
on the floor
[Music]
[Applause]
not shooting at fair so
atlanta will put it in play
tucker commits now you're wondering how
long is it going to take trey
to get loose and to get that ankle loose
now finally john collins back on the
floor here
shot out most of the third quarter after
picking up a fourth
foul here's young lost the handle
able to recover holiday all over now
here comes radus to help out nice pass
to chicago
sets it up for collins not able to
convert
that's a smart play there foul there by
trae young stop that fast break
boy drew holliday was all
over trae young like a blanket on that
last position